und das ist der ort wo gestern abend
peter er de vries getroffen wurde von
schüssen
man muss wirklich sagen dass das ganze
land wirklich unter schock steht ihr
habt gerade marcel fink vom telegrafen
interviewt ich habe gestern ganz ganz
lange mit marcel auch gesprochen er
konnte sich das auch nicht erklären
man darf auch nicht vergessen dass hier
journalisten in den niederlanden
tatsächlich auch unter unter enormen
druck stehen es gab vor jahren einen
großen anschlag auf das
redaktionsgebäude des telegrafen und
also die sind hier wirklich alle sehr
sehr sehr aufgeweckt man muss sagen dass
ich hier noch nicht genau versteht warum
es überhaupt passieren konnte denn es
hat gerade gemäldes nachrichten journal
dass unter den zwei verdächtigen einen
polnischer mann und ein rotterdamer dass
der schüssel hier verdächtigt werden
und jetzt muss die polizei hat weiterhin
erkunden wie das hier ausgeht ich gehe
noch mal ein bisschen zur seite hier in
dieser in dieser parking garage soll
herr de vries seinen wagen geparkt haben
jetzt müssen wir eben bisschen zur seite
gehen weil hier kommt tatsächlich auch
noch autos zur seite eine sekunde damit
wir keine überfahren
ja ja ist aus dem rtl boulevard studio
gekommen da war hat er an einer sendung
teilgenommen weil gestern hier bei der
rechts bank am gericht in amsterdam ein
prozess begonnen hatte und zwar ging es
darum einen mord aus dem oktober 2009 10
damals wurde ein friseur tot in seinem
wagen gefunden dass das kleine kind des
friseurs musste diese tat wohl noch
angesehen haben und da hat gestern der
prozess begonnen bei dem auch peter de
vries dabei war als berichterstatter als
beobachter und auch natürlich als
experte ich kann nur sagen ich folge
herrn de vries schon seit jahren auf
twitter weil das ist wirklich hier der
mann in den niederlanden der wirklich
tief in diese kriminellen strukturen
recherchiert der auch meiner meinung
nach für journalisten ein großes vorbild
ist nichtsdestotrotz lebte er wie marcel
fing es gerade gesagt hat wirklich auf
auf schweren fuße weil es immer die
befürchtungen in rede stand dass man
eben auch was tut gehen nochmal ein
bisschen zur seite wir können ja mal ein
bisschen näher rangehen
also haben ganz ganz viele personen
schon blumen hingelegt der könig hat
sich heute morgen noch einmal geäußert
beim staatsbesuch in den in deutschland
in berlin er hat gesagt das ist ein
schrecklicher anschlag auf die
demokratie sei auf den rechtsstaat und
auch auf den freien journalismus und auf
den journalismus überhaupt er auch das
land stark gemacht habe
zudem habe er auch keine weiteren
details ich habe gestern abend noch die
pressekonferenz mit ihm ihre route
geguckt und mit justizminister grab
house man konnte auch den
kabinettsmitgliedern wirklich ansehen
dass es für sie unerklärlich ist dass
das in ihrem land passiert
sie fanden wirklich keine worte und
premier rutte hatte dann noch mal gesagt
dass es wichtig ist dass der mann das
überleben
das krankenhaus hier in amsterdam wird
seit der tat von schwerbewaffneten
polizisten gesichert die landeeinheit
steht davor es kommt keiner rein der
nicht rein darf die leute werden
gescannt
ihr habt gerade im studio auch noch
darüber gesprochen dass das ganze
zurückzuführen dass eventuell auf einen
prozess dem orang prozess auch die
anwälte die dort verteidigen sind gerade
unter polizeischutz
und hier in den niederlanden in dem
kabinett in der zweiten kammer ist
gestern abend noch eine diskussion
entfacht wie solche leute zu schützen
sind politiker sämtlicher parteien haben
sich gestern geäußert dass sie wirklich
fassungslos sind die tageszeitung haben
hier kein anderes thema noch bei den
leuten ist er wirklich kein anderes
thema als die beiden schüsse auf peter
er de vries danke für diese ersten
eindrücke dort direkt vom tatort wo ja
wir mit dem herzen auch gerade sind und
bangen um das leben von peter de vries
vielleicht noch einmal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen
du hast gerade ein paar neue fakten auch
in deiner
reportage vom tatort genannt die ganz
wichtig sind deswegen noch mal hier wir
haben einen neuen ermittlungsstand einen
neuen informationsstand mittlerweile wir
haben eben von drei tatverdächtigen
gesprochen die festgenommen wurden einer
dieser männer ist auf freien fuß
gelassen worden wieder dafür gibt es
mehr informationen über die beiden
tatverdächtigen die zwei tatverdächtigen
wie es jetzt offiziell heißt dabei
handelt es sich wie es du es gerade
schon angedeutet hat michael um einen 35
jahre alten mann polnischer
staatsangehörigkeit der soll sein
wohnsitz in mauritz haben und der zweite
mann soll ein 21 jahre alter mann mit
wohnsitz in rotterdam sein
die beiden verdächtigen die befinden
sich in der zeit eben natürlich hin haft
werden am freitag wie es aktuell heißt
im untersuchungsrichter vorgeführt und
in der nacht und am abend gab es
natürlich hausdurchsuchung bei ihnen in
vielen mauritz in rotterdam das sind
jetzt ganz aktuell die informationen die
von den ermittlern aus den niederlanden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren